волонтери Сенцов на фронті кольченко на
фронті цей білет Вадим конец тюрма це
теж фронт боротьби і цей ганьба це МОЗ
диявола ми будемо його бомби це наше
відчуття цей реальність це природне поки
Крима окупованої спокою України не буде
чи може Україна погоджуватися на якісь
компроміси чи транзитні режими стосовно
Криму країна і українці ніколи на це не
погодиться але й не де виходить такий
Брос як пам'ятаєте в березні Минулого
року що треба Крим витащити за дужки на
5-10-15 років це не працює Тому що
відразу був резонанс особливе в Криму
серед наших співвітчизников і не тільки
тут середини України але і серед
партнерів зараз вже українцям не треба
роз'яснювати пояснювати що Крим
захоплювався ні для того щоб його
зробити привабливим а для того щоб потім
і Чорноморський басейн взяти під
контроль і взагалі Україну примусити
здатися оце стало очевидно Я три роки
виступав практично там на тиждень раз в
Верховній Раді намагався донести вони
аплодували вони слухали але я бачив що
вони не розуміють нарешті зараз
змінюється його та стратегія деокупації
Криму коли його приймали на РНБО
нервовий був Я чесно кажучи я це
коментувати коли там
дипломатичним путём тільки дипломатичним
щось таке сьогодні коли
секретарем було виступає і каже що
пріоритети змінюються іде військовий це
каже про те що нарешті Всі розуміють
вони змушені рахуватись думками тут
зсередини суспільства і наших партнерів
Ви ж знаєте що американці і Дехто сната
з європейці відверто кажучи поки Крим
окупований спокій України не буде А я
вообще взагалі считаю Я вважаю що без
Крима не буде незалежна Україна чи
принесла якусь користь кримську
платформа Кримська платформа Взагалі
вона створювалась щось 14-го року це
була ініціатива між кримськотарського
народу лідера Мустафи джмільєва тоді
сафагая і росте момерів мій колегам і
друг вони виїхали поки ми там в Криму
намагалися чинити скажемо політичний
опір акванту коли ми відмовлялися від
Перемоги вони вже створювали Таку групу
підтримки України в питаннях Криму тому
що ви пам'ятаєте після олімпіади взагалі
захоплення Криму вважалось такою
гібридною як Трамп сказав Ну там же
русский всегда були Да він же руський
був коли
я звільнився перша Моя зустріч з
президентом з п'ятим президентом Петром
алексеевичем я запропонував зібрати вам
каре президентом держав для того щоб ми
нарешті почали
створювати платформу для Криму але коли
президент запропонував Я маю на увазі
Зеленський запропонував створити
кримську платформу ми всі підтримали
тому що це завжди буде на користь єдине
що ми казали щоби ця Кримська платформа
не була гаслом на той час багато гасел
взагалі влада нам пропонувала Кримська
платформа вперше установочна сесія
пройшла тут в Києві і вона пройшла дуже
добре багато держав приїхала ні всі були
так однозначно на позиціях
того щоби були такі більш рішучі дії по
відношенню красі щоб вона звільняла Крим
Але це був перший крок і потім згодом ця
широкомасштабна війна показала що це був
правильний крок потім ми створили
кримську платформу парламентського
виміру і оцей хорватський саміт
Кримської платформи парламентських
вимірів Він був дуже такий потужний
показовий ну по-перше в європейських
державах всі знають що на рішення уряду
або президента в дуже впливає в
парламенті він є однозначно таким
показником впливу суспільства і це була
важливо і тому я сам був брав участь на
цей платформі де я чув деякі меседжі які
вперше з'явились перше - це Крим треба
визволяти
такий щоб вивела свої війська другий
Путіна потрібно до трибуналу і третій
меседж щоб пов'язували Крим з кримськими
татами і це було дуже важливо розуміння
того що Крим Кримські татари Україна -
це є першочерговим це і впливає зараз на
думки експертів на думки генералів
військових наш партнерів на те що Крим
військовим шляхом де окупувати це та
реальність яку яка є сьогодні ви як
ніхто інший знаєте як це бути в
російському полоні що ви порадите
Кримським татарам які зараз перебувають
у Криму як поводити себе під час
повзучої мобілізації єдиний шлях - Це
або виїхати з Криму або сісти в тюрму
тюрма це те що фронт боротьби і наші
політв'язні вони показують що на цьому
фронті Ми теж маємо потужну Перемоги Ми
не даємо їм спокій ми змінюємо ситуацію
в тюрмах лагерях знаходить щось у них в
руках ти відверто кажеш про свої погляди
Відверто з ними борешся І знаєш що
мабуть цей білет Вадим конец Але це твоя
боротьба комендації де можна взяти зброю
в руки а потім тут на
лінію фронту там здатись полем по-перше
це нереально це не така війна коли там
можна взяти білий там прапор і ти
здаватись по-друге це артилерійська
війна війна і тому ти більше ж
вероятность того що ти будеш 200-м на
першому плані це гідності Як ти будеш
пояснювати українцям що ти взяв зброю бо
цих фашистів знаходишся
серед тих хто вбиває твоїх
співвітчизників ми знаємо що ваш
помічник зараз воює у збройних силах чи
багато татар та колишніх політв'язнів
зараз перебувають у ЗСУ так і на жаль є
втрати серед політв'язнів А я вважаю
поки ми не повернемося в Крим Ми не
можемо бути колишніми Кожний з нас
намагається допомагати балувантери
Сенцов на фронти Панов на фронті
кольченко на фронті ми всі допомагаємо
це і є наш вклад в цю перемогу після
закриття АТР Чи достатньо української
інформаційної присутності в Криму чи
виконуєте телеканал дом свою функцію
телеканал дом - це ганьба в Криму
користуються поки є можливості
інтернет-ресурси І багато хто дивляться
на 5 канал він традиційний Тому що це є
Simple першого Майдану да чи по 2004
року і довіри більше і найголовніше те
що
там не в баюкою зараз точить це багато
дискусій що робити з Кримським мостом
після деокупації Яка ваша думка ми вже
показали що цей мост не буде
функціонувати в тих сенсах які мав
окупант Росія Сьогодні він те що вміє
виконує до кінця
функції він буде контрольований Україною
а там вирішив для початку для визволення
Криму ми будемо його бомбити що ви
думаєте про ідею повернення історичних
назв кримськотатарським містам у Криму
це природне для кожної нації це не
просто декомунізація дерусифікація це
подолання наслідків
того мовного геноциду зараз
продовжується боротьба за смислення яким
буде Крим після нашої Перемоги буде
українським і
кримськотатарські це є природа ми
визначились що далека до того як Криму
дали русскую автономію ще повертаючись
на своїх батьківщину знали що Крим - це
Україна ми боролись в 90-х роках коли
весняна намагалася становити там вплив
на всі називали українцями в Криму це
наше відчуття цей реальне це природно Ми
ніколи не дамо щоби України була занадто
мала